so both y'all are in Miami now yeah we
both in Miami yet okay how do you guys I
mean I know you guys are awesome he
moved me to land because he was down
there having a good air time every day
and I was in Atlanta working out working
hard it is the thing that's why he
moving like it's tax-free like so no
state tax exactly because you guys were
in L.A exactly so I was making a million
you know you're making a lot of money
but it's you give them half your money
to Uncle Sam give him half your money to
Joe Biden for him to send that [__] over
to another country you know what I'm
saying Joe Byron Joe Byron hey at least
Ukraine straight right young guy hey boy
oh God he got no straightforward he got
his own country straight like I don't
really if Trump spins the block are you
guys going to vote for Trump
if I had to choose between the A and the
B I definitely go with Trump overbite it
for sure
I choose not to speak on politics you're
a smart man
I believe anybody would choose that
light though
let's do a writing if you know I'm gonna
probably just write in I'm gonna write
in Swae Lee yeah because bro trouble
[__] with trouble [__] everybody
[__] well he had to eat here I mean
listen
he free Lil Wayne like he did Kodak
everyone tapped in more than buying them
I speak on the politics I'm gonna talk
facts like I ain't scripted I got points
behind my you know I'm saying my
politics I'm gonna speak on the point
I'm gonna have some facts to back it you
feel me so
if a [__] had to choose between hey bro
it's tapped in with with John Legend
though
come on man
I'm the Trump free Lil Wayne
and Kodak and Kodak Black and ASAP Rocky
come on man he actually tapped in like
he also normalized a lot of crazy [__]
but you know that's neither here nor
there
uh most he did
it's it's I ain't saying like if I ain't
saying my go-to guys neither one of them
my go-to guys but if I had to choose
yeah if you had to choose but if you was
at home if I had to choose if I only had
two options Joe Biden and Trump that's
what I'm saying let me clear it up
because you know how they get what you
know you could just hit them with the
heart neither
if they had if they asked me
the president of the United States can
either be Joe Biden or Donald Trump
right and those are my only options you
definitely want to party with Trump over
Biden that's for sure that's what I'm
saying he got a lot of he got a lot of
Pros more Pros than than Joe body you
feel me Joe Biden got more cons up like
Trump
um be on this business you know what I'm
saying yo whatever happened to your pet
monkey that Molly Maul gave you by the
way Molly Maul just got out yeah free
Molly no he's already out he's home
yeah yeah he um
I got the monkeys there well one of them
it was actually crazy because I didn't
have my USDA license so when I was on
tour yeah you gotta have a tour because
my monkey got famous in L.A my monkeys
was famous in L.A so everybody was
wearing on the street I swear they got
the monkeys right he had this party you
can go to this parties you can see the
monkeys when they run around drinking
alcohol with you jumping on girls
titties and [__] like you know what I'm
saying it's like they had a bad
reputation so well you had more than one
monkey I had two yeah I had two monkeys
I used to like when I raised them I used
to have one on their shoulder one on
their shoulder like in the studio boom
feed them they bottles like they
actually like ripped both of my ears
like my ears like sliced like my diamond
rings came out like it pulled my diamond
rings out damn like really raise them
since like little babies like diapers
like change shitty diapers like
everything like then what it was my
first kids like but yeah right now I'm
working on getting a USDA license you
know where are they at though did you
have to give them away one of them they
had kicked like my door in my Mansion
Dory when I was on tour and they took
like they ran in my house and took my
monkey like the the animal control
people I guess they were it's like they
kidnapped a kid literally my [__] was
really illegal like and I really need
somebody to uh help me and give me some
assistance with that if you're watching
this interview and you know how to like
get a monkey back yeah get the monkey
back because it was illegal some illegal
[__] going on and they took my monkey
all right where's the other monkey the
other monkey is with my family members
in a very safe location yeah
allegedly dude money back yo had a pet
tiger in his backyard
flash [__] it's exotic [__] like we
Kings we supposed to live like kings yo
two monkeys one's gone one is in a very
undisclosed safe location
allegedly did your did your monkey ever
jerk off
um it got to the age before I lost it
where it started like discovering what
it's like private parts were so like and
it would like sometimes like grab the
[__] it didn't jerk up but it was like
my grandma could like grab her [__] and
be like looking at it and just like oh
it's a grill Mark so like when I was uh
it was like 2010 I was at Ma's house and
he had his monkey bubs and his monkey
had you probably met bubs this is like
he had a wild monkey a Capuchin so he
had a portable DVD player in his cage
and on the portable DVD player he was
watching a Curious George cartoon and he
was stroking his dick
while watching a cartoon monkey I swear
to God Church the first time I ever
brought two chains over to Molly house
this is like 2010 and we were tripping
out because we were watching a monkey
jerk off while watching a cartoon monkey
that monkey was Advanced bro that's the
next level turned to a human you know
how the monkeys evolve to humans that
one is close to evolving into a human
because
that's like a normal thing you want to
do is beat your meat my dog don't beat
it to me bro dogs be licking their meat
they be licking their meat yeah cause
they don't got hands so they gotta lick
their meat that's making Next Level turn
on the movie
balls balls hey yo hey nah so my I have
a friendship who he'd be sucking himself
off for sure pause yeah I mean you know
I guess if you could do it none of us
could do it we can't say hey yo it's not
gay hey it ain't gay
no it's not no no I'll be having a
threesome with my hands
foreign